this story is fun because we are
traveling again and i never thought i'd
say that i mean it's just so crazy and
this story is so fun okay so a lot of
people are headed to the romantic city
of venice italy that's right they're
writing gondolas strolling canals and
apparently shooting seagulls with a
water gun what i know okay so the i i
heard this headline too and i was like
wait a minute what because i love
seagulls uh-huh i i i
oh yes look okay i have a chapter in the
book i wrote and the chapter's called
the seagull well what's the chapter
about
i always covet other people's food
and i think that i might be as
aggressive as a seagull i'm like
literally if you've does anyone have
that syndrome too like
oh you ordered the other thing and now i
can't stop staring at that thing or
maybe i just want to eat everything at
the table and
i just
have a little
[Laughter]
and since i was a kid i have coveted
everyone's food so they called me as a
nickname the seagull that is hilarious
so food and wine reports that venice has
an aggressive seagull problem and
restaurants are providing guests with
table side water guns to squirt out if
they get too close to your old spaghetti
olive oil
they tried using an irritating sound
that humans couldn't hear but they could
didn't work they tried unleashing
falcons a bigger scarier bird didn't
work
they'd say so they settled on super
soakers this is kind of what i like
about the seagulls though
is like they're scrappy and tenacious
you can't just easily get rid of them i
like that yeah but a squirt gun works so
the thought the question is right if say
i had a plate of fries right here and
drew was being like a seagull looking at
my fries if i had a squirt gun
[Applause]
you want to try it
just try it barrymore
okay well first of all okay oh
[Applause]
it worked it worked it worked
it worked
[Laughter]
i got a whole nother
[Music]
you